I think this is the place welcome home
Aaron Paul and Emily Ratajkowski steamed
up the screen as boyfriend and
girlfriend in their new romantic
thriller welcome home but in real life
they're both happily married I know you
have the coolest spouses in the world
but for me I would be a little like
please don't watch this please don't
watch this how do your spouse's react to
watching a movie as intimate as this one
oh they love it yeah your wife loves it
I mean you know I I don't know she gets
it you know she's been she's been with
me for a long time and before did she
choose to watch it did she look away at
certain scenes I mean I'm sure she's not
you know overly excited when like sex
scenes come on the screen but she gets
it and she she read the script and she
really loved the story and you know
she's a fan of Emily how does your
husband feel we weren't together when we
shot it but honestly I mean I think well
there's a couple things to be said like
actually a theme of the movie is like
voyeurism and like where is him can be
kinda hot so yeah we never know we're
saying okay I'm ready to fix this right
we're not gonna wait until we do I love
that this couple in the movie despite
any problems continues every single day
to fight for one another what makes you
wake up every morning and choose Lauren
and and choose Sebastian this is the
feels so blessed to wake up next to her
every morning so it's just the idea
holding on to that and never forgetting
ya better I mean I think that you know
love is not something like you don't
choose the people that you fall in love
with but you know it's a kind of like
transcendent magical experience you do
have to fight for that and work for that
and I think like kind of holding on to
the magic is really important Aaron and
his wife Lauren celebrated the ultimate
milestone this year becoming parents to
a little girl named story every time you
post a picture of story ah we just gush
a little melt a little yeah what has
been the most exciting thing that she's
done recently oh my gosh she's she's
waving now is a cutest thing in the
world when you wave at your little she
recognized a girl and she waves back
which is such a sweet smile yeah she's
just the best I see you lighting up does
this qvh at all hearing all this yes and
no I mean I think like as a woman it's
like it's such a commitment having a
baby engine
I like definitely I just feel like there
like there are certain things that even
my mom who obviously had me like I'll be
like it does this happened during
childbirth and she's like I've never
heard of that like I just feel like
women don't always disclose everything
that come like having a baby in like
what goes on in their body and like I
hope that people will start talking
about that more yeah but I'm not like
rushing to anything Brett breastfeeding
is no joke yeah it is I use Lauren but
dad isn't the only new role Aaron
tackled this year he's also set to join
season three of Westworld what was your
reaction when you read your first script
um you know I haven't read any scripts
but we don't start until next next march
of the we March April but what they told
me about
the world and this person was very
exciting so are you a host I may or may
not be three words to describe what your
character will bring oh man um I don't
know I can't say anything
excitement exciting exciting danger
suspense honesty oh yeah I give you four
I love it
[Music]